en senegal los enfrentamientos entre
manifestantes y policía continuaron el
jueves por la noche como aquí en el
barrio de iguacam de Dakar las
hostilidades más mortíferas tuvieron
lugar en la capital y yang shock donde
Guzmán sunco es alcalde también hubo
manifestaciones en San Luis en el norte
y en otras ciudades del país
el candidato presidencial y más acérrimo
opositor del presidente magistral ha
sido condenado a dos años de cárcel por
corrupción de menores una condena que
podría impedirle presentarse a las
próximas elecciones justicia es decir la
verdad justicia exculpar a nuestro
presidente usmansoncó ahora podemos
dejarle ser candidato en 2024
estamos dispuestos a acompañar al
presidente usman usanco a la victoria en
2024 porque es el líder de la juventud
no forma parte de este sistema corrupto
por su parte el gobierno asegura que no
ha interferido en la decisión del
tribunal
Nadie puede obligarle a declarar una
violación cuando no está convencido de
ello pero al mismo tiempo Tampoco puede
haber presiones de planes
insurreccionales
para asustarles y que le absuelvan al
final el juez falló según su convicción
personal y eso que refleja refleja la
imparcialidad del juez y la
independencia del poder judicial
de momento
que podría detenerle en cualquier
momento no ha dado fecha ni hora para su
arresto